welcome to the dave ramsey show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the dave ramsey
show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host dr john dolone ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author
is my co-host here on the air today open
phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
as we talk about your life because dr
john's here are you talking about your
money
cause i'm here and i'll interrupt him
anyway because i own the show that's how
it works that's how our that's how our
little
interaction works that's how most of my
life works
at home my wife owns that i was gonna
say i'm always interrupting you what is
that you own this part so it's good
okay well everybody's gotta have a gift
that's right open phones at triple eight
eight two five
five two two five let's start with
cameron in los angeles hi cameron
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave thanks for having me on i really
appreciate it you too how can we help
well i'm new to your plan um i just
found it uh
maybe a month ago and um you know i'm in
serious amount of debt uh right now i
have a total of
745 000 worth of debt
and um you know i'm really really
anxious to get out of it you know
made some mistakes and uh i didn't even
realize that you know
i was making them but after hearing your
show you know i really think that you
know i want to
get my life you know straightened out
and uh you know
i want to aim for financial freedom
okay um what kind of debt
do you have so um
i have it all broken down well i have a
home and it's 525
000. i feel better already for real i
just exhaled
i was afraid you had 745 000 student
loan debt or something i didn't know
what to tell you okay
but yeah 525 000 on the home what's that
home worth by the way
so right now it's about seven we're
worth about 700. okay cool
all right and what's the other 220
thousand i have
uh 150 in student loans i have
you're gonna get set but i have 20 in
timeshare
and um 30 personal loan
10 in car and 10 in credit card
okay all right and who's the person
loaned to a bank
uh yeah okay all right and are you a
doctor or a lawyer
uh neither a nurse practitioner no oh no
that's good
okay all right i thought i thought with
that student loan bill there may be
something
involved here so what are you making
so right now i make a hundred
and thirty-five thousand good news and
you're what twenty-eight
[Music]
150 to 180 in the next year excellent
excellent okay good well you're not
afraid of work that's good news
all right are you married no
okay cool so uh
what is it you want to accomplish here
i um i just you know i made a lot i made
a lot of mistakes
and i kind of just want you know the
best way to get on track you know
um i'm the first in my family to you
know
to ever graduate college and even have
you know some level of success with
money and you know i want to make sure i
change you know my family's tree so well
congratulations
that's awesome that was a bad note and i
want to just fix it
it's a wonderful start good for you it's
awesome man oh
well the the the the bad news is there's
a mess
uh the good news is that the hole that
you're in uh compared to the shovel that
you have 130 to 180 income
is uh this is very doable okay
uh so it just depends on how quickly you
want to do this and how deeply you want
to sacrifice
obviously the more deeply you sacrifice
the quicker you'll get out does that
make sense
yes because we'll use more of your
income to clean up the mess
the more deeply you sacrifice and or you
sell that house and you've gotten rid of
most of it
so not suggesting you do that but i'm
just saying those are sacrifices
no life no house but the debts all gone
and you start fresh
and you could do that pretty quick i i
don't think i would in your case
i think i would if i were in your shoes
i'd hold on to the house
and let's uh plow through 220 000
worth of debt making 150 to 200.
um let's just play with some numbers if
you put 50 000 on it
uh or 75 000 on it it takes you three
years
which is 2 000 bucks a month no it's not
i wish it was two thousand bucks a month
it's not even close yeah it's way more
than
six thousand bucks a month thank you but
um anyway yeah if you do that that's 75
000
a year you'll be debt free in three
years
translation you have absolutely no life
you're working so many overtime shifts
your eyes are crossing
you are living on beans and rice rice
and beans you are not going on vacation
and you're not going to see the inside
of a restaurant unless you're working
there's your extra job which you
shouldn't do as a nurse practitioner you
ought to be nursing as your second job
okay i can do that i can do that i kind
of think you can i know you can
i think you're the guy because did you
follow the math with me 75 times three
is two and a quarter
yes yeah but 75 000 bucks
6 000 bucks a month out of your
income means you're working extra and
you are living on
nothing and you're going to list these
debts smallest to largest and you're
going to attack them
with a vengeance in your community
who has seen you as the guy that got out
the first guy to go to college the first
guy to get the big fancy job the guy
that works in the hospital
is not gonna understand why you're
driving a crummy car and working on the
weekends
they're not gonna understand why you're
not picking up the tab
and that's why they're broke and this is
the this is the gut-wrenching moment
when you change the family tree
with the hard hard stuff now honestly
cameron the
the people that have done this stuff
that we've worked with over 30 years the
ones that are the most successful
care the least about what other people
think
caring what other people think it will
kill you
on this so if broke people are making
fun of your financial plan you're
always on track
okay i really appreciate it so really
quick you
you don't think i should get rid of the
house not unless you have to
if you if you can if you can lean into
it for three years
if you if you want to move anyway okay
that's fine but if you want to hold on
to a piece of california real estate
which is not a bad idea
and you want to lean into this and bust
it
then i think you can keep the house and
still be done in three years or sooner
if i thought it was going to take you 10
years i'd sell the house
okay but the math says it's not if
cameron says
he can do it and it's all up to cameron
now but we'll help you
we have a thing called ramsay plus and
we're going to give you a one-year
subscription to that
and that puts you into the financial
peace university class it puts you into
the every dollar premium version of the
budgeting app
it puts you into the baby steps tracker
it connects you up with all the tools
like the death snowball tool
it connects you with everything you need
to be able to move to the next level
and to cause all this to happen
including community and coaches
and everything else i'm going to give it
to you because i just want to start
this hour that way and you are on i
think he's going i'm just going
man he's going to do it i know he's
doing it call me back give me that free
scream man
i'm smiling brother i love it three
years from now i'll be sitting here
waiting on you
hold on kelly i'll pick up we'll get you
signed up
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters
with easy online ordering free shipping
and a guaranteed perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
so have you ever seen the movie trapped
in new york
it's not a real movie but it's really
happening and we should be filming it
right now
uh anthony o'neil's been up there six
days in quarantine in order to get to do
the ryan and kelly show i've been
hassling and he is a man he's stuck in a
hotel room
so we wanted to call and harass him a
little bit because he got to be going
stir crazy
anthony how are you are you making it
dave john man
i'm i'm barely making it i'm not gonna
lie i'm ready to get home are you
ordering room service just to see people
i really am and i'm looking out the
window looking at cars driving by and
i'm waving up
top so but it's good though this is new
york city they don't wave back
yeah exactly they really don't they
really don't they're looking up and
laughing at me to be honest
they just they just sent out a bulletin
saying strange person waving to others
up there this is so on new york
man oh man so um seriously you is your
dr john's here is your mental health
okay having been trapped in a room by
yourself for six days
anthony i'll go ahead and tell him so
he's been texting me while he's gone
dave he's not doing good he is not
unraveling right in front of us no
man i'm i'm all right i'm making it i'm
making it but it is boring
uh and i miss the family though but hey
we're here to help people so i'm good
i'll sacrifice for the people if it
wasn't for our people days
i would not have done it i told my wife
that uh my friend anthony was gonna have
to spend six days by himself in a hotel
and she just paused and said i can think
of no greater heaven
six days without me and the kids in a
hotel in new york but
yeah thanks for taking one for the team
anthony yeah you're very bad
you did something the rest of us were
willing to do um so
uh uh alex gave a great introduction
during staff meeting this morning on the
new podcast coming out
and uh we need to let everybody know
that anthony o'neil has a brand new
podcast as of today right
yes sir yes sir it's a drop zone apple
spotify pandora
and it's still on youtube as well but uh
it's it's the new
uh podcast right here on the ramsay
network uh the table with
anthony o'neill feels so weird to say
anthony'll know what i'm anthony
but yeah it's the table with anthony
o'neil it's going to be a great great
podcast day
so what is the i know but i'll give you
the underhand pitch
why is it named the table
well it's named the table because
actually you know our tribe called it a
table but i really wanted to make a
place
in a space where people can feel
comfortable to come and have a real
relevant and relatable conversation uh
when it comes to dealing with our
finances when it comes to building
healthy relationships
when it just comes to life in general
you know you think of the table
are you thinking about coming somewhere
you having something to eat and you're
just having a good time
you just get comfortable at the table
you just talk and and you listen
and you laugh and sometimes you may cry
and sometimes
you may argue and so i wanted people to
know like hey hey here at the table
we're gonna have some rough
conversations
but we're gonna also have some life
transformation conversations
especially around finances relationships
and just
building true success yeah how to become
how to have a
quality well-rounded successful life and
really i think this kind of was
i guess it was expanded uh
maybe it was born a little bit all on
the subject of racism
and uh i mean we you use that platform
to
have some uh difficult conversations
during a time that everybody needed a
place to talk right
yeah we did we did we did um it was last
february uh when we launched the black
history panel and it was just so great
because it
it it pretty much burst out of that and
so we just kept the table
uh going from there and dave you know
we're bringing that actually back
uh next week uh the uh black history
piano it's a special edition of the
table
and i'm really excited about that i'll
be on the podcast shopping monday
through friday
next week on podcast and on my youtube
channel so we're going
back to where it birthed where it
started uh but man it's there's the
conversation from there though is just
so much more than just racism
but it's really just about how do we
build a true successful life
here's what i learned dave a lot of
young people want to be successful but
they don't know where to start
and how to make their dreams become a
reality so i literally
uh created a space where i can walk them
through that entire process
john's been on the show dave hasn't been
on the show yet
uh but he'll be on next month so i'm
well not next month he hasn't been
in the first quarter been on my show
either anthony don't take it personally
you know well it's
you know there is this thing you have to
be invited oh here we go
so here we go you two stop your bonding
i don't walk into your room with my
buddy boots on besides that i mean what
are you gonna call it the boomer edition
i mean come on
i love it remember no dave you're on
i've already gone with uh your assistant
and you're already scheduled for a day
so i'm looking forward to it because i
want to introduce
uh you know our tribe over there in the
ao circle just um the cool
uh honest transparent fun cool relatable
dave so
i'd like to hang out i'd like to meet
that guy too so i'll be listening to
that episode anthony
that'll be good if we run into him we'll
send him right over we'll send him over
that's right
yeah this is gonna be great it's gonna
be great because the types of people
you've had on
on the youtube version of this uh
you know ian kron talking about uh the
enneagram
the uh anti-f downs has been on matthew
mcconaughey's been on i mean lots of
quality
folks have been on just to lead anyone
that's willing to watch
or listen to the table on podcast or
youtube
to give them a better road map for their
life
yeah yeah yeah dave and it's so funny
today when we launched the podcast
matthew mcconaughey is on there
and he's talking about three key things
that has helped him build his wealth
and has helped him build his success in
the acting career and the man is
he's just getting straight down and
being very real so i would encourage
everyone to
get the podcast and listen to the
podcast and i got to say this when you
come to the ao
uh the table with anthony o'neil you're
going to learn how to build wealth
and develop strong relationships and
find out how to have the hard
conversations and get advice
you need to be successful around your
finances and mental health so
i would encourage you it's going to be a
fun conversation but i promise you you
will walk away
with something that you can apply today
that will change your future but you all
know me the caliber of our future is
determined by the choices you make today
and you're going to make the right
choice by subscribing to the podcast
because together we're going to grow and
go further
along in our journey anthony o'neil it's
called the table
check it out on all podcast locations as
well as youtube
and john when anthony comes back you've
got to debrief him
and make sure he's okay he's a mental
health standpoint
after having been trapped in a room by
himself for six days
listen there's a limit to what i'm able
to do
there are practicing professionals that
he's gonna have to sit with it's gonna
be a minute
i subscribed this morning um personally
i uh
obviously you're one of my close friends
here but i can't wait to
to dig in and listen to this myself and
i'm i'm grateful for you man
it's going to be super successful you
can help a lot a lot of people yeah you
will i'm so proud of you sir very well
done
looking forward to big things yes i
appreciate you and john
all right anthony o'neil ladies and
gentlemen you can check him out at
anthony o'neil dot com
of course uh one of our ramsey
personalities has had
multiple best sellers had a number one
with a
debt-free degree and of course destroy
your student loan debt as a follow-up
that we did from that
he's done all of that stuff you've been
preaching about student loans for
years and years helping people with that
and so
this is going to be amazing this this
guy is really caught a stride he's he's
in a zone
you know it in this world we get to meet
a lot of quote unquote influencers and
people who
are so excited to see their name in
shiny lights
and that drives me bananas to be honest
with you
and it makes your heart swell when you
meet somebody like anthony that behind
closed doors
is so passionate not about having his
name look shiny but about
helping young people helping new adults
helping
folks who are making that transition
from 20 to 30 30 to 40
not have to walk in that walk that he
did that if you cannot sleep in your car
man if you cannot
have train wreck relationships that's
he's so passionate about it and so the
the influencer part is
just simply a vehicle for him to help
other people and he loves it man
and that's just that's just me talking
about my friend and so i love how this
thing is taking off and i love how
successful
he's been how authentic he's being it's
just it's it's awesome just to get to
sit by it and watch him yep absolutely
he's doing really really good work i
agree
anthony o'neil be sure and check out the
table
spotify uh itunes google anywhere where
you're picking up podcasts you can get
them there
and of course the youtube version has
been there for a while and we'll
continue to add
it'll be the same exact content only you
can watch it for those of you that are
youtubers and um he's got quite a
following there oh man
vastly popular so this is the dave
ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
you know health care has gotten to be
ridiculous
it puts people um you know on the brink
and so it would have put us on the brink
had we not had
chm chm saved our life same problem
financial lives
christian healthcare ministries or chm
is not health insurance
but it is a budget-friendly option and
the original health cost sharing
ministry for christians
learn more today and check us out at ch
ministries.org
that's chministries.org
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
this is the dave ramsey show open phones
at triple eight eight two five
five two two five adrian is with us in
long beach
hi adrian welcome to the dave ramsey
show
hey dave how you doing thanks for taking
my call better than i deserve how can we
help
um so my wife and i started the
financial piece this month yay we're
currently on
baby step one which we have about five
hundred dollars at a boy
um but we want some advice on what we
should do with our vehicles
um currently i make around 35 000 a year
my wife makes 52. um we have 110
000 in debt and the vehicles we
currently own my wife's vehicle
is 24 000. my vehicle is a lease
which has uh 22 000 left and i'm already
over mileage
and i just don't know what to do here
i kind of want to get rid of them i just
don't know what to do okay
all right well the rule of thumb that we
use on cars
is two things if you like them and want
to keep them
the only way you would want to keep them
mathematically
is if they total up to less than half
your annual income
which these two barely do but they're
right around it
uh and you can be debt-free not counting
your house
without selling them in two years or
less
and that's questionable here so both of
those things point to selling
one or both of these cars and it sounds
like the one you're fleecing is the
biggest mess of the two
so if we're going to start we'd start
with that one probably
right yeah that kind of sounds like the
conclusion you'd already come to
yeah and i was thinking about it's just
i don't know
i was just a little confused because i
don't know how to sell it if i wanted to
sell it should i just buy it outright
no and then well you have to you have to
buy it outright and sell it
simultaneously here's how you do it
okay there's a couple of numbers you've
got to gather up to figure out what to
do
number one who who's the car fleeced
from who's the fleece with
taylor who tell you that
toyota toyota i'm sorry i'm definitely
supposed okay
toyota all right and so you're going to
call toyota motor credit
and say uh here's my account number what
is the
early buyout on the fleece
if i want to pay it off today and you
send me the title
okay so on it's like having the payoff
on your loan if you had a loan
but that's not what it's called on a
fleece okay
now it should be at the end of your
lease
there is a figure that you can buy the
car for
after the lease is over and you have
your remaining payments if you add your
remaining payments to that figure at the
end of the lease
that's your total exposure on this car
and the
early buyout should be less than that by
a lit by a couple thousand bucks anyway
a few thousand dollars
so how much is left on the fleece how
much before it's over
uh it's 22 000. no how many months
uh i got one more year left february of
next year
okay so you have
so 22 000 includes the that you've
gotten the early buyout it sounds like
well i looked up on my you know on my
account
it says 22 000 left on below okay no
that's not the number i'm looking for
all right you got to call them and you
got to get the early buy out
okay because that number that number is
the number i'm talking about it's the
total of all your payments remaining
plus your buyout at the end
how much is your payment okay it's about
uh
400 yeah okay and so you got like 5 000
bucks of those
plus you got a 17 000 buyout at the end
it sounds like
does that sound about right okay great
okay
and so anyway let's pretend that when
you call them it's 20 000 for the early
buyout
that's probably not going to be that far
off somewhere in that range
okay then you look up on kelly blue book
and find out what the car is
worth private sale have you done that
yet
yes and it's about 21 000. good
okay so you can sell it and pay them off
and get out basically about even right
right that's awesome and then we've just
got to get you a thousand or a 1500
car that you pay cash for and we're
gonna drive that hooptie for a little
while
while you get yourself out of debt now
we're gonna do the same thing with her
car if we can't get you moving and get
you out of debt
okay either one of you got overtime
available
yes what do you do to make 35 grand
uh i'm an estimator and a construction
company
okay so what are you going to do for
extra income
i was thinking of starting maybe a side
business doing some power washing
i love it you know i have that uh all
the equipment here at the office and
they tell me i can use it freely so
that's what i'm talking about there you
go
you're the man right there man you can
double your dead gum income that's right
yeah and you're gonna yeah that's a ton
that's awesome
yeah there you go and now we're gonna
put you on on a budget
and you guys aren't going out to eat and
you're not going on vacation we're gonna
list these debts smallest to largest
we're gonna attack these debts in like a
vengeance
and uh so now we've got like eighty
thousand dollars i'm sorry ninety
thousand dollars of debt left
after we get rid of your car and if we
do 45 a year for two years out of 87
you're debt-free in two years
right awesome and i think that's i think
that's doable but it's going to require
extreme
focus and concentration and no one takes
your eye off the ball
and lots of lots of saturdays and
sundays starting early power washing
power washing until it gets dark getting
up and doing it again
sounds good the next two years are power
washing that's your that's and then
after that you're going to hate power
washing for the rest of your life of the
california water crisis my friend
[Laughter]
single-handedly yeah that's right but
they will be shiny and clean right
everybody's gonna be clean there's not
gonna be any mold or mildew no
i love it well done yeah hang on man i'm
gonna get also put you into ramsay plus
because you need to be in there
going through financial peace university
he said he was already in it no
he just uh just started the just i think
got got word of it
okay if he's not already in it put him
in it as my guest we're gonna take care
of him
eric is with us in cincinnati just
giving everybody stuff hey eric what's
up man
hey thanks for taking my call today sure
how can we help
uh well i need your permission on buying
a
vehicle no you don't buy my dave car no
you don't
i'll give you an opinion but you don't
need my permission you're a grown person
yeah yeah i hear ya so um
i'll give you my stats i'm on four five
and six
um and i i think i'm in the right place
to purchase this vehicle i don't wanna
buy a new one i wanna buy a toyota
tacoma and
i don't want to buy a new but i want to
buy it like two or three years old
and so um that's what i'm thinking about
doing i've got the cash
to do it um what's it called my
i'm looking to spend about 25 to are you
married
yes what's her car cost
um well she is a business car
through her work so she doesn't have a
car in her name the business gives her a
car
correct okay yes all right and what's
your household income
uh about 115. okay and you have your
emergency fund in place and you're out
of debt
except your house correct yes
i'd buy it okay it's a good truck
all right i just wanted to make sure i
wasn't like overstepping or
uh do you know how i did that
all right i think how you did it was
that
it's less i have less than half my
household income
in in things that depreciate value there
you go
right yep you're paying cash okay
yeah and you have your emergency fund in
place so it's not an emergency you buy a
taco
but tacos are great trucks my wife
uh she likes to have an emergency to the
emergency fund i like her
yeah and so she's very much like yours
and so i'm just trying to figure out
we would be dipping into the emergency
of the emergency fund
[Laughter]
hey eric you're a smart guy and you
clearly have worked together with your
wife to
to get an emergency fund get out of debt
do all the stuff the right way trust
your instincts and trust the math man
you guys are doing good stuff very well
done very well done tacos are good
trucks
got a couple of them in the ramsey
family this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings you
get free samples
free shipping and with the new promos
they run every month you'll save even
more
use the promo code ramsey to get the
best possible
deal all right today's question comes
from joshua in indiana
joshua asks how can i start to rebuild
my relationship with my son
after being absent for a long time after
years of fighting with his mom she got
custody and was able to move
16 hours away i'm trying to learn to
slowly rebuild the trust with him and
start moving forward what is the best
way to start
man there's a lot here i'd want to know
how old this kid is
and for some reason she was allowed to
move 16 hours away so i want to know
what your what trust you're rebuilding
from
but at the end of the day dave i think
it starts with contact and
intentionality
and being accountable to yourself what
does that mean that means i'm gonna call
on the same
at the same time every week that means
i'm gonna facetime at the same time
every week and
no matter what i'm not gonna miss that
i'm gonna save my money and come to a
basketball game if i can
i'm gonna write handwritten letters so
he's got a legacy
of me reaching out and when i say i'm
gonna do something i'm gonna do it
and i'm gonna be real intentional about
being in that young boy's life
but this is the key here man is you're
playing a long game now
joshua um you're not gonna fix this in
six months i can fix this in two years
this is one of those things that you
want your son to know that you
were relentless in pursuing him when he
turns 25 and when he turns 27
and um that's hard and
we don't know what all happened here
obviously um
my tendency and i think i'm gonna guess
and call it a human
tendency would be
to um want to tell my part of the story
and that's probably not useful it's
almost never ever useful
um because most of us want i want to
defend myself there you go
you know and i want him to like
take my side kind of right i think
that's kind of a human thing
and most of the time in these situations
that's a counterproductive isn't it
right that's it unless one day joshua is
old enough to process it
and that's not 21 or 25. well and and
that's not him asking in the first
conversation what happened and you go
well you just don't know about your
mother
absolutely not and and you do whatever
you can
to stay neutral or be positive about mom
but when parents start running each
other down
to try to look better in the eyes of
their children they're seeking approval
from children
right and a child can't carry that
weight they can't carry the
complexity of my dad's a good guy and
does things that i don't approve of or i
don't like
at the same time it takes most of us
until until we're adults until we're
parents
before we realize just how hard it is
to be to be a grown-up to be an adult
right and there's things i
love love love love about my old man and
there's things i'm doing differently
with my kid
and that all is in the same package all
the same guy and i love it all but
that's also part of the human condition
i didn't understand i don't think
there's ever been a human that goes i
want to do it exactly like they do
if you do whoa that's strange you should
see somebody too right
yeah exactly but yeah dave
telling yourself the story doesn't help
um almost never
unless there's just some abuse mom is
very sick and in these
situations it's rare that someone is
sick or abusive and gets to move 16
hours away yeah
right yeah that would be unusual and
joshua if it's appropriate here
start the conversation with i'm sorry or
your daddy messed up
and um he's working as hard as he can to
show you that he loves you
and teaching humility teaching
vulnerability is a big thing for dads
yeah the um
yeah there's how do you rebuild trust in
any situation where
your spouse doesn't trust you with money
i get that one a lot yup
uh because i messed up i overspent and i
had credit cards and
and now 10 years later i'm still not
allowed to touch the money
because she won't trust me or he won't
trust me you know well
how do you rebuild trust you first have
to be worthy of trust that's called
trust
worthy right and that's what you were
talking about early in this discussion
here which is
the steadiness the consistency keeps
showing the predictability
part of tr when you if you if you um
want to step out on the ice
do you trust the ice what you're asking
is
is it predictable right will it can i
count on it right is it going to crack
and i'm going to fall through
or is it solid enough ice that i can
step out on it and not end up in the
river
and so you know the trust is about
predictability consistency
um it's a type of integrity the word
integrity is where we get our word
integer or it comes from the same word
we get the word integer from which is
any whole
number no fractions i like that
and so for you for your math nerds but
yeah
integrity is wholeness and it's like so
you can't be
uh one person on sunday and two people
own uh
i mean another person on monday another
person on friday night there you go uh
that's that's fractured
right it's not worthy of trust that
whole
there's no hole but the challenge here
is you can't hold the outcome
he could theoretically show up
and be a great father from here to
kingdom come and this young child may
never come around
he can't hold that there's a point when
somebody
commits um financial infidelity and ten
years later
it's not their problem anymore their
partner needs a heart change
their wife needs to grow up their
husband needs to put that nonsense down
right and um you can't hold that outcome
you've got to continue to be
a person of integrity for you you got to
keep leaning in and leaning in and doing
it and doing it and doing it you can't
control what they can do
that's right and once you start chasing
their approval that's when you get
yourself in trouble you overspend you
do these weird big presents and weird
big trips trying to win approval from a
child
can't do it man you know i i just a
friend of mine recommended a movie that
apparently everybody's seen but me
what's that warrior
oh it's yeah it's good it's right on
right on this subject that's my mma
world man that's yeah that's good mm-hmm
stuff that's man i watched it the other
night it's
very much this subject yeah very much
the subject well acted well written too
and it's a beautiful story of
brotherhood and redemption and
sort of i wept wept that's right it's
kind of a modern day rocky but yeah
except better
and um yeah it was really good but i
thought that you know nick nolte
probably did need an oscar or something
like that that was pretty freaking crap
it's an old movie though was it like
2011
yeah it's it's been out for a minute i
guess i'm just the last of the party but
i got there
so yeah but it's the same thing this
idea that that
you can't just show back up and it's all
okay like nothing happened it's all good
that's right but that doesn't mean you
don't show up
right because the showing up heals you
from the inside out
right and you keep showing up and you
keep showing up
and there's that beautiful moment when
he falls off the wagon and his son's
there
his son knows right you keep showing up
man and redemption may not look like the
fantasy picture you have
and there's no there's no soundtrack
that swells and there's no people
cheering for you
but redemption almost always comes it
just looks different than we think it's
going
and it's it's like a lot of things like
a lot of healing it's messy yeah oh it's
a mess
because there's wounds yeah there's just
trash cans full of gauze over there in
the corner it's a mess it's gross
but it doesn't mean it's not the right
thing yeah yeah healing hurts
everybody but so john nothing else
joshua
there's just we know the data there's
millions of dads who don't even ask this
question
mom moves 16 hours away and they give up
they cash in
and they sit there and lift their wounds
and they chase whatever addiction is
gonna
numb that hurt that son's gone and
wife's gone
and kudos to you for saying i i don't
want to be that guy
i want to rebuild and what can i own
here man i'll tell you you can own
almost all of it
and just get to work being a dad's heart
dave
yeah it it it is and you know meg meeker
does a lot of really good writing on
this strong father strong daughters and
uh hero dads
and her her books and materials on the
power
of father even
being absent i'm reading his line here
for a long time
still showing up well christy wright's
story yeah chris he's got a great
redemption story yeah
on this on this process and it's just
it's a powerful
uh thing and uh it needs to happen so
yeah
i commend you i'm with john on this
joshua i commend you on
doing that but i think it's good to
remember whether it's in business
or working with an audience um
you guys relationship with us that are
out there are we worthy of trust are we
consistent
um you know i get one of my biggest
criticisms is you know dave you're one
track
you know you one trick pony you don't
have but one thing to say over and over
and over and i go yeah yep
but i always say the same thing that's
right
you can count on it yeah i would never
violate never
violate it because just one time it'll
make the front page of the paper oh man
just one time you're inconsistent in
someone's mind
they're begging for a reason to
to to carve you out right to cancel you
in the cancer culture just begging for a
reason
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the dave ramsey
show
where dad is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status of symbol of choice i'm
dave ramsey your host
open phones this hour as we talk about
your life and your money
you jump in we'll talk about your life
we'd love to have you dr john deloney is
my co-host today
ramsey personality best-selling author
of the book redefining
anxiety you can call here at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five and we will talk adam
is in cincinnati hi adam welcome to the
dave ramsey show
hey good afternoon thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
uh my wife and i recently finished
painting overhead except for our home
and i am blessed to get a seven and a
half percent
match on my 401k for my employer
wonderful when i'm
calculating uh saving for retirement do
i
do 15 excluding that match yes okay
and then should i put all of it into
that or should i only put in
to get the maximum match and then put
the rest in a separate account
well uh the rule we use is we call it
kind of rock paper scissors except it
only works one way
and uh that is match is best
so for sure the first seven and a half
we're doing right
uh well i have to do five percent to get
seven and a half you have to put in how
much
five percent okay then the first five
percent is a no-brainer okay
we're gonna do the match first then
we're gonna do roth now they offer your
401 k in a roth
i'll have to check i doubt it because we
have a big
company that we go through third party
so i doubt it i think it's just
a slate of index funds that we can
choose to invest in
who do you work for it's a company or a
large
what it's a large company well most
third parties are offering most
third parties are offering roth i mean
if they're with like
if they're like with fidelity or they're
with a tiaa
or they're with uh whoever most of those
would have a roth available if your
company chose not to offer it
that would be what's unusual
okay so let's pretend both ways and then
you'll have your answer
okay number one we're gonna take the
match the second thing is we're gonna
take roth because the best thing is
double your money
in your case more than double your money
five to seven and a half the next best
thing is tax-free growth
and the next best thing is the
traditional which is tax
deferred growth you don't pay taxes on
the money and you get to grow money with
what is going to be taxes someday
and so that's your last mathematical
choice
but none of them are horrible choices so
we're going to take your five percent
match and then we're going to do a roth
now we if your company offers it and you
have good options and you want to do it
all there
that's fine if you want to do a roth out
as an individual
roth for you and your wife you can just
get in touch with one of our smartvestor
pros
and sit down with them they can help you
select the types of mutual funds we pick
growth growth and income aggressive
growth and international
spreading it across those four evenly
but then if you've maxed out roth and
you still haven't gotten to
you putting in 15 let's say for instance
your company does not
have a roth and you go do a couple of
roths individually
and that plus your five percent is still
not 15
then you'd go back and do some
non-matching traditional
in your original 401k so dave
i've worked at multiple places over the
course of my career and every place is
different when it comes to match
what is a when a company's thinking
through what the match is
why does it vary so much is it is it a
matter of how much money
the company has or is it we're gonna we
pay a little bit higher salaries
here so we match a little bit lower here
or what's the thinking
it can be anything uh obviously well not
not necessarily in most cases the match
is vested instantly
okay meaning that if you leave it goes
with you right okay
very unusual for it to not be uh the
second thing then
is um you you're using the match
to not only be generous to the team but
uh
in some cases in most cases somebody
wants it to give you a reason to stay
it's a it's a it's like consciousness
it's like being paid well okay it gives
you a reason to stay i get paid well
here so i want to stay here right
and so i got this great match it's it's
a bit of a golden handcuffs thing
right i wouldn't want to give up this
match and so you know
if i'm going to give this job up i'm
going to give that match up and oh boy
yeah
you know but if they go well they don't
match anyway and then put match over
here
so it's a competitive thing for hiring
or retaining
team members uh it's a way to be
generous
um when i see a seven percent match that
makes me think something
whether they're being super generous on
the back end or they may
compress salaries a little bit over here
or
maybe i'm just a cynical guy there or
maybe they're trying to make it hard for
you to leave
yeah seven and a half is unusual that's
high i've never heard that
well i've seen 10 i've seen up to 15. i
had an eight one yeah
i did but but it's an unusual number
it's usually five
or three right right and most of them
are 78 of the companies match
right now okay something so not matching
anything leaves you
at a disadvantage from the standpoint of
hiring
or retaining to other employers who do
so that's
it's a competitive advantage so to speak
um
but but probably it's a huge company
i'll give you a guess okay
uh 10 15 years ago or more
they did away with their old pension
plan uh okay and they converted the
money that they used to dump into that
and they moved everybody out and a bunch
of people were pissed they moved them
all into 401ks and so they just
did the math and it came out seven and a
half and they left it and they just did
it even if you're not putting in seven
and a half that's what that's a real
unusual thing there they're given a
match that's
higher than what he puts in right that's
very unusual yeah i hardly ever say
that's just a free two and a half
percent then yeah that's uh uh
very unusual so it has something to do
with something else
that's well that's what i'm wondering
probably and i've never
been a ceo of my own company that way so
but if you you know the old-fashioned
pension plans like when i started the
show
20 years ago there were a lot more
pension plans there were 401 cases
and every year they just kept dropping
and dropping and dropping and dropping
it because people started getting on the
10k
well they're very yeah yeah very
expensive and the 401k
you control your destiny yeah the the
team member controls their own destiny
they can become a millionaire and lots
of people have with their 401ks
um and just steadily investing and you
take it with you when you leave you roll
it to an ira when you leave it's yours
you don't have the pensions got all
these rules on it and you know do i buy
more years do i wait until i
you know do i will i'm 62 or 63 and a
half
or all this crap and nuanced stuff you
have to get into with a pension the 401k
is just real clean
real simple the cost to the company is
two things whatever you match and the
cost of the administration
which with a thousand employees here our
administrative bill is
you know it's just south of a hundred
thousand dollars a year yeah just to
keep up
with the dadgum regulations you know but
but uh
and that's money that just you know goes
out to quote professionals right
to do this stuff and you know i'm not
mad at them or anything but that's all
based on
federal regulations scared death
somebody's gonna screw somebody yeah
with a 401k
uh and and so that's money that doesn't
go into our team's account
uh but we've got a match here and uh for
a long time when we first started our
match
didn't start until you'd been here a
year yep
because we wanted to make sure you're
here before we start giving you money
you know extra money
and so it was more like a long-term team
member
thing now we started now at 90 days
after everything else we started
immediately or whenever when's your
start
remember i don't remember right i don't
remember this first day or 90 days
but like all our other benefits are set
up same way so but
as we've gotten bigger and have a little
more money yes we've relaxed some of
that
good questions this is the dave ramsey
[Music]
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help get you there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
dr john dolone ramsay personality is my
co-host today this is the dave ramsey
show
do you feel like you'll never save
enough money or pay off
all your debt and if you're a year like
2020 most of america feels that way
but money should not be one more thing
you have to worry about
and that's why in 2020 we are hitting
reset
because no matter what's happening in
this crazy butt
world you can take control of your money
you just need the right plan ramsey plus
is our step-by-step plan
that helps you get quick wins so you can
make real progress on your debt
because once you get all your debt out
of your life you get your money back
and you can be more generous and invest
and become wealthy
that means you can finally start
spending and saving money without worry
and get the security that you need right
now so here's our challenge decide on a
total money reset this year
then start ramsey plus commit to working
hard
the first 90 days watch all those small
daily wins
we will show you exactly what to do the
first 90 days
turn into lifelong habits so you never
feel out of control again you can get a
free trial at ramsey plus
for free just by going to daveramsey.com
reset daveramsey.com
reset nick is with us in greenville
south carolina
hi nick welcome to the dave ramsey show
hey dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
well four years ago i got stupid saw
chapter 13.
uh moved in with my sister she kicked me
out in july
so i came home once no ain't no big deal
man the dog jump in the truck
well i made the last payment on that
chapter 13 today and
then can i tell them they can have this
truck
you made the last payment on the chapter
13 today you're living in your truck
what kind of truck you talking about a
semi
yes sir okay so you're driving over the
road
yes sir and i'm so tired of this okay
now i do have the va
so you know i don't really need like the
down payment or anything
i'm just curious you know i know it's
not gonna i don't know
did is was the truck did you have it
financed in the 13
oh no sir no sir i'm a company driver
i'm not an owner operator oh
it's not your truck no sir okay
all right so you're just you're just you
and the dog are living over the road and
you're sick of the road and you finally
got your 13 closed up
so all your bills are behind you yes sir
i mean i'm debt-free i just don't have a
house yeah
so what are you going to do for a living
if you come off the road
i don't know if i may i may go back to
running a city or
find something completely different okay
cool what do you make now
about 60. do you have any debt at all
um no sir okay do you have any money
um after today no okay i don't think i
got million dollars
you're done and you're done so you're
going to be driving a little while
longer agreed
yes sir yeah i mean i'm not trying to
jump out of it today i mean i'm just
looking realistically
how long am i looking at because 20
years is too long i got you
i got you we need a better plan this
this one doesn't this one doesn't scale
well
i got you and i and i agree with you by
the way how old are you
22 cool you're obviously single
yes sir okay all right what i would do
is rent
before you buy i wouldn't worry about
buying today
because with the chapter 13 it's just
obviously messed up your credit you file
bankruptcy
um and yeah you can get in on the va and
they'll be more
lenient on that but i wouldn't today
um instead i if i were in your shoes i
would say all right
if i drive x number of months let's just
pick out you pick out a number and i
you what let's call it six months i'm
gonna drive for six more months
and i'm gonna pile up uh ten thousand
dollars
okay okay i'm just making this up
whatever the numbers work out you you
decide if it's eight months fine if it's
five months fine i don't care
and if it's not ten thousand dollars if
it's eight thousand dollars that's fine
but you need a little nest egg
between you and life because life's been
kicking your teeth in for a while
okay yeah a little pad like ten thousand
dollars would make you walk a little
more
uh a little strut a little more rather
than walk right
yes sir okay uh and then i would just
get me an
inexpensive one-bedroom apartment rental
and get me an inexpensive two thousand
dollar car that i pay
cash for and i would line up a job that
gets me off the road
i'm sorry my pickup was my pickup was
included in the check
13 and that's paid off oh good so you
got a car i don't even have that
okay yes sir what's it worth uh
16 ford f-150 i had an offer for 16-6 i
think
okay all right that's a lot of car for
where you are right now if you want to
hold on to it you can i don't care
you got it paid off uh or you can sell
it today and have fifteen thousand
dollars in cash in your pocket right
right that'd be tempting to me and get
me a five thousand dollar truck
um and have ten thousand dollars in my
pocket and go ahead and start looking
for a job to come off the road and
looking for a little one
apartment to come off the road and get
your life set because your rhythm right
now
is throwing gears that's your whole
rhythm and i want to reset your rhythm
into not being out of town you and the
dog
have an apartment uh or a little small
home of some kind something
it doesn't have to be much because
you're not going to be there forever
you're going to be there for two years
while you finish
this transition out of the 13 and off
the road
does that make any sense yes sir
and nick there's some there's some
literature out there there's some
nerd research out there that talks about
what it's like to sleep in your own bed
for 60 days
for 90 days and your whole body your
whole
mind starts healing itself and there's
something about showering
in your own place and sleeping in your
own place and suddenly
you things clear up when it comes to
thinking right and then this
new job this dude what am i going to do
next some of those things get a little
more clear
because you get a little more stable and
a little deeper sleep
if i were you i'd start looking for a
job today as soon as i found one i'd
sell my truck get me a 5 000
truck and come off the road if you can
do that no we gotta do it
and i got i got i got fond memories of
just me and my old hound dog in a one
bedroom apartment for a couple it was
awesome man
no doubt right and just kind of
you know and then just kind of get you
know off the road no bankruptcy
no crap flying around your head and you
you get
a calmer more uh uh
more calmer more peaceful rhythm to your
life
and then that allows you to start
growing your career into the future
that allows you to start you know
plugging into a good church
that allows you to start working out
again that allows you to
uh uh you know think about buying a home
two years from now and start setting
some goals on all of that
and um if you were my little brother
that's what i tell you to do
if you want to keep the truck and wait
four months or five months and pile up
some cash that's fine
i would personally you know i think
you'll get you another truck someday
soon
and i would rather personally be off the
road and get this fresh start if i were
you then own the truck but that's just
me
you get to decide that as to how quick
you want to do that but
uh to me that is an unusually large
item value-wise in this story
yeah it stands out in this story
and so i would use it to reset my life
and get in a slower peaceful rhythm that
i can use to build my wealth
build my body build my spirit build
relationships again
because you're just you're just gone all
the time you're throwing gears man and
when you don't when you're sleeping in a
truck you're not all the way asleep
you're not sleeping for seven eight
hours at a time you're not getting that
you don't have that place to anchor into
yeah yeah
and it sounds like there's some
relationship steps you need to work on
well let's go back and call on your
sister and slowly start to heal that or
healing some of those old relationships
man but having a good place that you
anchor in so that you're
steady and you're having that just peace
man
yeah um then that's a great place great
news is you're free from the bankruptcy
it's all in your rearview mirror so you
get it you got a
whiteboard you got a brand new day brand
new year brand new thing
yeah as soon as you can find a job if
i'm you i'm gonna sell the truck and
come off the road
yeah and i start looking today that's
that's you do whatever you want but
that's our advice for you listening to
you
and i really really appreciate the kind
of guy you are that you're
you're a guy that just scratches and
scraps pushes through
makes it happen me and the dog jump in
the truck and got her done yeah you know
i love
60 grand crush doing a great job man
you're working your butt off you're
going all the time
i love that and um i just i think the
next phase is going to be so much better
for you
you got some real cool things in the
next 12 to 24 months for you
if you make real careful wise choices
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
cliff and i joined christian healthcare
ministries because we really liked the
concept of
christians sharing each other's burdens
and we really experienced that firsthand
when cliff
was diagnosed with heart disease it was
just such
a relief to know that financial burden
was going to be taken care of
chm is the original and longest serving
health cost
sharing ministry get started today and
check us out at
[Music]
chministries.org
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
eight eight two five five two two five
adam is in dallas hi adam welcome to the
dave ramsey show
[Music]
hey dave thanks for taking our call sure
how can we help my wife and my wife and
i we are
currently working through baby step two
we are
about halfway through that process
um and my question is my wife is
she's an operator um of a woman's
retail store and we eventually are going
to have the opportunity to
purchase that store outright um
at the end of 2020 she
received kind of i guess it would be
like a bonus
from the company so our question is do
we
do we put that aside in some type of
fun to save to purchase that business
down the road or
do we throw that at our
snowball and try to help us get out of
baby step two with that money
i'm a little bit confused this sounds
like a big company in one hand the other
thing that sounds like a local boutique
and she's buying out this a single store
or is this a chain
or is it a franchise
it's it's a pri it's it's not a chain
there's there's multiple stores
um ours would be the the local store in
the
in the little town that we live in that
we would be purchasing
and other people do that in their towns
or is this the first time the company
sold one of the company stores to a
former employee
right this would be the first time yeah
do you have any idea what the store is
going to cost
um we we have a figure yes
how much we know the number on that 400
000. okay um well let's just talk about
the business aspect for a minute then i
want to buy a 400
000 business uh you're in debt and baby
step two which tells me you do not have
any money right uh
not not the kind of money to buy that
store right now i don't know
well if you're working baby step two you
should not have any money but a thousand
dollars and all of it should have been
applied to baby step two
unless it's in a retirement account
right is that where we are right i mean
that's where we are yes sir okay so you
don't have a hundred thousand dollars in
a mutual fund sitting to the side
somewhere
no okay what do you make
about 75 a year what does she make
um around 100
what's the net profit on that store do
you have any idea
not profit on the store you know
after she's paid her 100 right
uh yes okay all right well 400 is not a
bad purchase price on it then
that's a fairly reasonable valuation if
it includes all fixtures inventory
receivables and everything
um that's not a bad price the biggest
problem is you don't have any money
so um right okay let's go back to your
original question and then let me solve
the problem on buying the store okay
because i want to try to do both if
that's okay with you
um sure number one is how big is her
bonus coming
um it was 30 000. and how much debt do
you guys have left in baby step two
we are right at 45 that we have left
okay so let's pretend that you set 30
000 to the side
and uh you don't use it to get out of
debt
then you've got to pay off the 40 000
yet okay
or let's pretend you use the 30 000 and
you get out of that that much faster
and the in the exact same period of time
that you could have paid off 40 000
worth or thirty thousand dollars worth
of debt you could put back the thirty
thousand dollars
right so if we go to the end of this and
there's thirty thousand dollars
in your account and your debt free
you'll get there in exactly the same
speed
regardless of whether you pay down on
the debt and then you use the
fact when you're debt free to build the
account back to 30 or whether you use
the 30 to knock it out now
and then you build the account back to
30. i mean you leave the 30 alone and
you just pay through it
or you use the 30 and get out you're
going to get out in the same speed
okay at the end of the story now so
i'm going to pay it on the debt for that
reason
um and because you need to be debt-free
before you talk about buying a 400 000
business the second thing i'll tell you
is that eighty percent of the small
businesses
fail in the first five years and the
number one reason they fail
is cash flow problems which falls under
two headings they screw up their taxes
they don't hold their sales tax back
they don't set their quarterlies aside
on their income taxes and the second
thing they get into
in cash flow is they get into debt so
you go don't have any money or you put
down 50
000 you take a 350 000 loan for a store
that's making a hundred thousand dollars
and a pandemic hits and you go out of
business
and you're bankrupt and that's what
normally happens
eight out of ten times i would tell you
do not do that
i want you to buy the store but i do not
want you to buy it that way
with 350 000 worth of debt with a 50 000
down payment with an sba loan on your
home
there is a high probability you're going
to fail and go bankrupt in that scenario
and i know you don't think that's
buzzable but it's very freaking possible
i've been doing this 30 years and i see
it all the time
so i don't want your dream of owning the
store to turn into a nightmare fair
enough
here's what i would do number one one
possibility
is you just pile up cash after you're
out of debt
so high that you pay cash for the store
that's one possibility now that's going
to take a little while
but you make 175 000 a year how quickly
can you come up with 400
probably four years you know something
like that right
are they going to give you that long to
buy it
um well i guess we're gonna
we're in a good unique situation as far
as
purchasing the store um the 400 000
would be interest-free right yeah
so it would just be oh they're going to
loan it to 400 000 outright
well not necessarily um
we still have to come up with the money
but um
it's it's interest-free um
you know we're not going to have to go
take out a loan or anything like that
but you're going to
you're going to owe them the money
you're going to owe them the money right
and until you pay them they can come
take it back if it fails
right yeah so they're going to own or
finance it great
that's the best of all worlds let me do
one thing if i can talk you into
changing the structure
just a little bit and you've got to talk
them into this and since they've never
done it before there's no reason they
can't be talked into it
here's what i want to do i would propose
to them
that if they're going to finance the
store for you at zero interest at 400
000 that is an awesome deal thank you so
very much
i want to pay you every bit
of the profit above 75 000
salary instead of 100 000 salary that i
can i'm going to give you a hundred
percent of profits above that
until the 400 is paid
that's going to pay that store off in
three years four years okay
and then now here's the nuance to that
i said all the profits above 75 000 and
you guys can easily make it in your
house
with your wife making 75 instead of
making 100 you making 75.
you got 150 000 income in my scenario
and 100 of the profits which is now 100
and a quarter
if our numbers are all right here are
going towards the 400 are you following
this
yes sir okay now if profits
drop because there's some weird pandemic
or something happens
you're not bankrupt because all you've
pledged them is a hundred percent of the
profits above 75.
so if the stupid thing goes down loses
drop drops way down
and doesn't net a hundred and a quarter
above 75 it nets
one thousand dollars above 75 you're
gonna give them one thousand dollars and
take home 75
and you're not in bankruptcy court and
they're not foreclosing on you oh if
profits drop to zero one year
you're going to give them zero because
they get a hundred percent of the
profits above
75. and if this all works out the way
you all think it's going to perfectly
which by the way it never freaking does
you're going to be out completely out of
this in 36 to 48 months under my
scenario
and you've done it interest free and
they've accomplished their goal selling
you the store it's a wonderful idea and
it doesn't bankrupt you
if there's a freaking pandemic this is
the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today
it's tax season or almost
[Music]
what's worse than a pandemic taxes
almost almost so by the end of this
month employees must
employers must send you your w-2 your
1099s
and many people put filing their taxes
off until later in the spring because
well who wants to sit down and do taxes
the only people that rush into it are
the ones that are getting a big refund
and a lot of them don't even rush into
it but folks let me tell you this year
you'd be wise to start your taxes as
early as possible 2020 was crazy
and a lot happened that can affect your
taxes if taxes were confusing or
complicated to you last year this is not
the year to do them alone
our team has partnered with tax
professionals across the country
who will help you get your taxes done
right
and done now instead of later
so text tax pro
to three three seven eight nine and
we'll get you some help with your taxes
that's tax pro no spaces
two three three seven eight nine tax pro
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today nicholas is in miami
florida hi nicholas how are you
i hate being afraid dr john how you guys
doing great how can we help
first i want to say thank you for taking
my call i appreciate it sure
um so
recently separated from the military
march of 2020 not by choice might have
made a few bad decisions uh
hung around some people that i shouldn't
have and uh ultimately got separated
early
um it wasn't on terrible terms it was
still an honorable discharge but uh
i just couldn't finish my contract
so early on in my time in the military i
purchased the vehicle
uh just as you do as you know a lot of
people do in the military soon you get
that paycheck
so purchase the vehicle for about twenty
two thousand dollars
uh put zero down on it and uh
the payments came up to around 470
around that a month
um i made the payments for about the
first four months or so
and come the fifth month or when the
fifth month
came around i missed the payment and i
just snowballed from there
and i didn't end up paying on the car
for about a year and a half
and for the better part of the year and
a half uh around like a year
three months and the car never got
repossessed um
during that entire time wow um are you
still
you still have the car no so it got
repo'ed in um
so i i got the car finally in june
of 2019 yeah uh paid for it for about
the first
three to four months so now you have a
repo
okay yeah or sorry not 2029 got the car
in uh
uh june of 2018 and i got repo'd in may
of 2020 paid for for about the first
four months
so um car got repo'ed um
and um you know they sell it to auction
and nicholas what's your question
i i wanted to know what
should i do because i i i owe
i owe the uh about this offered me a
settlement of twenty four hundred
dollars
for the car uh during the time that i
got the car
i also bought a pair of tires uh
and i didn't end up paying on that so uh
i owned the tire the car's about twelve
hundred dollars
i got a settlement offer for that as
well for about two hundred fifty dollars
okay so twenty seven hundred dollars
solves your problems
and i have a thousand dollars in credit
card debt okay um
thirty seven hundred dollars problems
what's your income
so i i just got a job i make
conservatively speaking about 1500
a month and as of right now i am a
full-time student
um i was looking at purchasing a vehicle
that was like the main thing i wanted to
purchase a vehicle this week actually
i'm about three thousand dollars saved
and um i wanted to get a car um but i
wanted to know how are you getting
around now
uh i use my grandma's car
and and is it an extra car or why is why
are you able to use her car
um well she she doesn't really drive
much you know she's
like said she's up 76 she doesn't really
drive at all so she just has it
for emergencies really for her but so
how much could you drive it for two more
months
um yeah i could but
she i could but it's not i
mean it's not going to inconvenience her
she's not driving it
you just don't want to how old are you
uh
22. ah okay
all right yeah so and i and jumping into
crap
jumping into crap that you can't afford
is caused you pain
right time to stop doing that
making decisions that you know aren't
right has cost you pain man
you know this is not smart so i'm going
to take
2 000 of your 3 000 and get rid of
2 000 of the 3 700
worth of debt which means i'm going to
get rid of the tire debt
and the credit card debt and then i'm
going to save towards 2400 to settle
that
stupid debt uh with a repo and
um you're going to be done with that in
about a month and a half because you
need to be working like a maniac
like six jobs while you're in school
full time i want you to have no
personal social life at all i want you
to do nothing but make money
and clean up your dadgum mess because
this is so stressful dude
it's not fun can hear your voice man
it's not fun you're not it's hard for
you to even think through this clearly
because the stress is so overwhelming am
i wrong
no no it's trying it's driving you nuts
you're not even sleeping good are you
listening you hit it right on the now
yeah i've been there man i've been that
scared and freaked out
and let me just tell you if you will
work like a maniac live on beans and
rice
use 2000 towards the 3 700
problem that you have and then knock the
2400 out in a month and a half to two
months from now
and then save up and buy you a car for
three thousand dollars
in cash by the end of sep
by september you're going to be
debt-free driving a car that you paid
cash for
and working a plan called your education
towards having a great life in the
future
now you got control of your dadgum life
right that sounds appealing to me
yeah i i agree my point honestly my plan
was
and i know especially hearing what you
just said i know you're gonna disagree
with it i was gonna
i i i was gonna get a car for
around six thousand dollars uh you don't
need
any more debt honey man don't do it dude
you know it's not been a blessing in
your life
you call me up stressed out not sleeping
because you got debt and repos on tires
and cars and credit cards
and no and no no peace that's why we
call our thing financial
peace two words that don't go together
you know so please don't do that honey
you do whatever you want to do you're
22. you're grown man you're allowed to
do it it's legal
but that doesn't mean it ain't stupid
don't do it i want you to reverse
engineer the last 24 months of your life
man
and look at the decisions that haven't
worked and don't
voluntarily walk back into them you've
already done it man
taking out a big loan it was probably
jeep it was stupid
and putting big tires on it was stupid
and
you've been given a gift to sell
to settle at the price that you've
you've been asked to settle
it's a gift brother yeah take it you
told somebody
i will pay you and you didn't and
they're offering your way out
do it go see one of the counselors that
you pay for at this college
go see somebody get your head screwed on
straight and don't make stupid decisions
on top of stupid decision you're smarter
than this man
i know you are it's you know ask
yourself what's going to give me peace
a new car payment is not on the list and
doing the same thing that
got you in this mess in the first place
it isn't the journey out take a new road
man
yeah first step to getting out of debt
don't borrow anymore
man big step big step you can do it you
call me back if we can help you anyway
we're here to help you man i've been
right where you are i've been scared
and i've been living in the poop that i
made and that's where you are
and um just you know the trick is don't
don't keep doing it
and i feel myself getting passionate
because i've been there too man pace in
the house just like yeah
walking around figure this out sweat in
the palm of your hands yeah
it's just not it's not fun it's not fun
so we feel for you we're not we're not
shamed now we're not picking on you two
old guys that have been there man yeah
we just um yeah i love you man i don't
want to see you hurt
yeah hold on kelly's going to pick up
i'm going to send you a copy of the
total money makeover thank you for your
service to our country sir
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional
about your character you can have money
and a career
you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the dave ramsey
show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host dr john deloney ramsey
personality is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five christopher is in scranton
pennsylvania hi christopher how are you
hey dave how are you great man how can
we help
good so i'm 23 years old i'm still
living at home
just finishing off my debt i have 6k
left paying it off
um so if you were in my position 23
years old what's your next step once
you're debt free should you invest
should i save more or save for a down
payment on a house
just curious what your what your info is
cool you're doing great man
congratulations thank you how much have
you paid off
uh started at 32 000. wow good for you
man
what do you make thank you uh 83 000
for here lord what do you do for a
living
i am a project manager excellent good
for you
thank you you're killing it okay thank
you
so you like that you're making great
money you like your job in your area huh
i do uh my job is it's a blast i really
enjoy it
um the area i i don't have an issue with
i don't like the winter but i think i'll
stick around here for a while sure
okay well we teach folks to become debt
free which you're very close to doing
to build an emergency fund of three to
six months of expenses
that's baby step three and then start
saving 15
of your income towards retirement
sometimes between
baby steps three and four between
getting your emergency fund done first
people will stop there and save up a
down payment for a house
before they start saving for retirement
particularly in your age group because
you got plenty of time to get after the
retirement
and you're not going to be sidelined
from retirement saving very long
to save up for a down payment on a house
so what would i do if i woke up in your
shoes
i would make plans to have my own rental
place
within 90 days
okay and i would rent for a little while
while i built up my emergency fund
and started saving for the down payment
on my house and
plus or minus start saving for
retirement but um
it's been my experience that it's going
to be very very good for you you make a
lot of money
you're doing really good i have a great
first job out of the gates man i mean
your income's amazing you've cleaned up
your debts um
being on your own is a great next step
right
right do you have a good relationship
with your folks
i'm sorry do you have a good
relationship with your folks
oh yes very close yeah man so leave it
on a high note
i love dave's recommendation right
yeah they um the good relationship with
mom and dad
makes my suggestion feel a little bit
um ludicrous because why not stay there
for rent free and build up some cash
that's what runs that's what runs
through mom and dad's head
because they don't necessarily want to
kick you out and it's what's running
through your head
i will tell you that the advancement of
your
adulthood will far outweigh
the uh your wealth building over the
next 10 years
by moving out earlier rather than later
um
their math their math is wrong and uh
the good news i mean i had one of our
kids live with us for a little while
right after college
and um and we love her and honestly to
this day she could live there and i'd be
fine i mean it did
we get along well and um you know all
that kind of stuff
it would not be an issue at all uh there
wasn't anything
driving her to leave or us to
throw her out or something like that but
man but she stayed about 90 days
and went out on her own and it just
changed the way she walked
it changed the way she talked it changed
the way she functioned when you start
buying your own groceries paying your
own light bill
it just changes stuff and i hear so
often
folks get to that that relational
tension where
mom and dad and you just can't sit at a
table hardly
yeah yeah hate it when they walk into
quote unquote your room but it's in
their house all that
leave on a great note leave when
everybody's um
when nobody wants you to leave yeah you
still have lunch once a week
go to lunch on sunday afternoons
together still and yeah be connected
still
watch the game with you with your old
man but um
leave while things are good and your
your financial footing is so strong
right now you're good to go
man making 83 at 23. it's a different
world
that's not the world i lived in that's
good man way to go man so proud of you
project management's great great field
great field for sure
well it is time to put 2020 behind us if
you're ready to own
this year and actually accomplish your
goals with your money your career your
life
we got the plan to get you there last
year left us all with wounds and feeling
stressed out so start 20 21 with our
newest quick read
redefining anxiety by dr
john deloney to learn what anxiety is
what it's not
and how to get your life back the best
part is it's just quick read it's only
10 bucks
and this year many of us need to spend
time connecting with god
to rest to reset christie writes new
women's devotional called
living true 40 days to get back to you
will help you feel like you again and to
help you with your money goals pick up
rachel cruz's brand new best seller
know yourself know your money this book
will help you tackle your money mindset
so you can make
real progress and reach your goals
even faster online store daveramsey.com
backslash
store to get serious make some real
progress
if i woke up in your shoes i would
probably buy all three of those
redefining anxiety
the new 40 days to get back to you
devotional and know yourself know your
money they serve three different
purposes and they're all
solid material and all best sellers by
the way
seen some neat things with that
redefining anxiety i've i'm
starting to get notes from counseling
offices across the country that are
buying them
10 at a time no way to give to their
clients on the way out the door
so they can say hey read this and then
the next session we're going to talk
about it and you've got some tools and
the counselors love it because it's it's
short and it's simple and it's
it's right to the point um and that's
fine
that's affirming yeah hey it is yeah and
when one focuses you kind of expected
some of the counseling community to be
mad at you about this i did yeah that we
distilled
you know thirty six thousand dollar
degree into about 85 pages but
um but yeah but i mean some of the stuff
you say is a bit
heretical in that world it is just
because it's simple and we tend to over
complicate things
and it was a it was a journey writing
this for me even to they
you guys kept pushing me back and saying
you're not talking to a bunch of
scientists man how can i help somebody
in their house
right now who's struggling at their
kitchen table and it's another fire it's
yeah it's it's really a gift but it's
neat that that's cool community's
picking it up yeah
that is i did not hear that yet that's
awesome cool well we need to
like come up with a bulk deal man that's
a good that's a good thing ten dollars
is not about that
ten bucks man shut up yeah shut up cut
the price even more
that's right cut down what john's going
to make on it but yeah
that's great the book is redefining
anxiety what it is
what it's not and how to get your life
back
three out of five counselors now
recommended three out of five dentists
right
dentists that's right three out of five
dentists recommend it
it is great it's a great read if you've
ever had or know anybody
that think like yourself that's dealing
with anxiety it is a
it's a must read and it's only 84 pages
there you go this is the dave ramsey
[Music]
show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters
with easy online ordering free shipping
and a guaranteed perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five cody is with us in
houston texas hi cody how are you
hey i'm good thank y'all for taking my
call sure what's up
i just needed some advice on how to
practice patience better whether it be
in my career or just life in general i'm
just
really impatient i've always been
peddled to the metal you know
climbed the ladder climbed the ladder
climbed the ladder and then covered it
and stopped all the ladder climbing
so i'm just getting kind of bored where
i'm at and just needed to figure out how
to
be more patient with my life and career
progressions
what are you running from man
i don't know i just i grew up super
super super poor
and i'm tired of being that away i'm in
a lot better position now than i ever
dreamed of being i'm just
i'm just trying to not go back to that
place
when you say you're in a better position
what does that mean
just financially i mean me my wife we
live a you know we have a good life and
better than my family ever did growing
up so i don't know i'm just trying to
make sure i don't end up back there
when you say good life give me a picture
of that you talking about financially
your marriage is good you got
your kids are healthy what's that mean
we don't have kids but financially
our marriage is good i mean we're we're
in our second year of marriage now so as
good as two years of marriage can be
during a pandemic but
um i mean we make really good money i
mean we're both young we don't have any
kids
yet thankfully because they're expensive
but you know what's uh what's really
good money
uh between the two of us about 220 and
you're how old
she's 27 and 26. it's really good money
that's great money
so sometimes when folks
have a picture of a life they don't want
to have they take off running as fast as
they can
another direction and that's often a
good thing
right but if your identity
doesn't become about building something
good but it becomes about
not being that then you're going to
always be running for the rest of your
life
and your identity will become as being a
sprinter and so
there's a way you can look at this
season you're making great money great
money
astounding money in a city that's not
super expensive
and you can look at slowing down as a
curse
or as wow what a gift man i can spend
more time with my brand new wife
and we can figure each other out that
becomes
you're talking about legacy shift
earning the money
changing your financial footing that's
part of a legacy shift
but so is having great relationships
deep rooted trust with
somebody you can anchor and rappel off
the edge of anything with
or survive any car crash with right
and so i'd love to challenge you
to come up with some practices that
when you start running from something
when your heart starts racing
when you get those looping thoughts in
your head i gotta go gotta go gotta go
that you and your wife come up with um
whether it's a code word or whether it's
a
a special meal or something that you
slow down and intentionally
practice being still there's one way to
practice patience brother and that's to
practice patience
i wish it was harder i wish it was more
complex than that it's not
um you have to decide that my life isn't
going to be judged on how many
zeros i have after my check they're
awesome
but it's not all of your life you're
gonna have to decide
that i'm gonna put prioritize some
things in addition to
changing my financial future right and
so
you're going to have to decide to not
spend your life as a sprinter
the tortoise always wins always
there is something to be said man you
shot out of the gate and that's
incredible man
what do you have an emergency fund you
guys got a home you all set up
yes sir we're in three b and four so
we're we're out of
two and we do have the emergency fund
set up
so now you got to do the hard work you
sprinted you gazelled out right yeah you
finished up the
intensity now you're gonna go to the
intentional and that's hard man four
five and six it's a gear change
so um how long have you been making 220
uh not that long in the last maybe six
months she just finished pa school so
when she got out and got a job it really
kicked it up
yeah so based on the math of what you've
told me
and you're all focused intensity and
your high level of motivation
i'm going to tell you that um 20 years
from today when you're in your mid-40s
you're going to have between
five and fifteen million dollars
yeah that'd be sweet now
the difference in five million and
fifteen million
in terms of what it does for what you're
running from
is zero five million gets you
as far away from poverty as 15 million
gets you
the only difference is which room you
stay in on vacation
and which how many lobster tail you
order with that steak
that's really the only and really with
either one of those numbers you could do
as much of either of those things as you
want to do
there's only so much crap you're going
to be able to buy
and the difference in 5 million and 15
million is merely legacy stuff
it's merely stuff you can do with
generations it's
merely things you can do with generosity
but your
actual state of well-being
the difference between 5 million and 15
million is almost nothing
the difference between 5 million and 15
million that you the price you would pay
psychologically emotionally spiritually
between now and then to have 15 instead
of five
ain't worth it is my point so five
five at five at twenty years from today
or
seven or ten at twenty twenty years from
today running a marathon pace instead of
a sprinter's pace
is all i want for you i don't want you
to have 20
and there's nothing left in your guts
and your kids don't know who you are
or they don't like talking to you or
you're on marriage number three
and i work i work with wealthy people
for 25 years man
and i am wealthy and so and
you know i get up on uh sunday morning
and go to dunkin donuts at six o'clock
in the morning and take the grand babies
donuts with sprinkles on them
and you know you can do that with five
million you can do it with 50 million
you can do it with 500 million
um you know and it really in the
laughter of the kids is really not even
gonna change
the car you drive yeah and that's
between the difference between
in other words at a certain point wealth
only begets more wealth it does not
change the your situation
that's right it doesn't change it
doesn't change your setting right
there's only so much i mean
when your home becomes two percent of
your net worth
instead of eight percent of your net
worth it doesn't change anything right
yeah it's not a
it's not a thing when it's a hundred
percent of your net worth that's when
you you are feeling that one
right you are feeling that one but um
but but there at some point
your uh
your environment is no longer your
personal lifestyle your environment is
no longer affected
unless you're just kind of some kind of
freak who's just buying you know stuff
like
you know whatever bling or you're trying
to just buy stuff to impress people i
mean
you can do all that but even then you
know you just got
another yacht that you have to work on
right
and they break down and so if you've
ever been hiking in the woods and you
turn a corner
and there's a bear you
have a built-in your heart races when
you go in the woods whenever you hear
something rustling you immediately
you've got to train yourself over time
to not see a bear everywhere
it's a rare occasion i've been in the
woods a million times it just doesn't
happen that often
it does occasionally but man
when you've seen poverty when you've
seen pain in your family question it's
just such a good i
do and it's so hard to get your head out
of that because
man our brains take care of us david
it's an interesting way to ask it
what's that how do i learn to practice
patience well that's somebody that's got
some wisdom and he's starting to see it
right it's not
you know i but i don't think it's
patience i think it's contentment that's
it
how do i practice practice peace
something this year that uh godliness
with contentment is great gain
i'm working this year to reverse
engineer the fruits of the spirit
what does it look like where do i see
peace where do i see gentleness
and where can i trace that limb back
instead of trying to do it over here i'm
trying to walk it back
i'm just going to open a can of
gentleness that's exactly that's not how
it works right so where do i see it
and i love his question because he's
certain what he's searching for
hey we got that money and i still i'm
not just falling asleep at 10 o'clock
yeah i'm still
water early promoter how do i just go to
sleep and i want to tell you
you practice peace you practice
gentleness you practice forgiveness
and slowly your default setting falls
that way yeah
that's good but he's on it and because
he asked the question and
that's a gift because he's not blaming
everybody for his lack of sleep he's not
chasing
pills he's not chasing anger he's saying
how do i practice patience they need
practice patients
by practicing patients there you go dr
john deloney this is the dave ramsey
[Music]
show
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country or have a
better life
the army national guard can help get you
there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
so
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the air mike
and marianne are with us in richmond
virginia
says on my screen you guys are debt-free
congratulations
thank you uncle james way to go
guys how much have you paid off we paid
off a hundred and
seventy two thousand dollars all right
and how long did that take you 27 months
wow and your range of income during that
time
150 000 to 200 000. very cool what do
you guys do for a living
uh i'm a small business owner and
general contractor
and i'm a fundraiser for university
health system
awesome way to go so what kind of debt
was the 172
thousand dollars uh we had
where i had a little bit of business
that um i think it was two vehicles
student loan
and uh some renovation loans for our
home
okay so you got just kind of normal very
normal pretty normal yeah no credit card
yet but yeah
how long you guys been married
we've been married almost three years
and our story is pretty cool dave we met
about 30 years ago through
church and even dated a little bit in
high schools and
went our separate ways married mike had
two children
we both went through a divorce and
reconnected about four years ago
and did what any newlywed and love
couple would do
we bought a house a 200 year old
farmhouse and
hundred thousand dollar loan so before
you knew it we were
almost five hundred thousand dollars in
debt wow
wow yeah yeah that was a big tipping
point for us for sure and
we were on a long drive and we heard
this dave ramsey podcast
mike had read the total money makeover
and in that process we looked at each
other and we said we could do this
we could too be debt-free i know that we
can make this happen as a couple
so mike you got her in the car before
you put the podcast on huh well played
strapped around for a long time nowhere
to go man
trapped crazy dave ramsey
oh my gosh oh man so how long was this
drive
i do think it was about an hour and a
half and i think she said hey
do you like podcasts and i i think i
said do you know who dave ramsey is and
that
that was that was how that started and
we were listening to it dave and we
we thought gosh these people are amazing
they're paying off hundreds of thousands
of dollars
we have that same problem is there any
way that we could do this
and i think we were pretty scared at
first but the second we got married we
combined all of our finances and we went
right into the snowball
and it really changed our life both
individually and then as a couple
coming out of two other two failed
marriages how hard was it to combine
your finances
uh that's a really good question i don't
think either one of us had a lot of
expectations
based off of our previous experiences
but because we
didn't have partners in our previous
marriages
um it was really fun to kind of learn
how to do this together and
there was no point of resistance at any
time
to to do this as a couple yeah and the
best part has been
doing it together and having that
partner what i tell people all the time
is that marriage can be wonderful
and the financial part of marriage can
be even better it can be a lot of fun to
dream and plan
and not only did we accomplish this goal
but every single day
we dream together about what we're going
to be able to do in partnership
man that's awesome that that's that's
the key to success especially in second
marriages
is being able to say we're going to
build something brand new together
and we're gonna plant it and see it and
dream it and then go make it happen and
good for you guys
that's incredible very well done very
very well done
all right you pay off 172 000 after
listening to a podcast in 27 months
what else did you do to get out of debt
and what are the keys for the listener
out there that this is
maybe they're in the car trap listening
to this podcast and they're
going hey these people paid off 172 000
tell them how you did it
yeah the first thing we did was we sold
a car we didn't need
uh we got on the every dollar plus app
which has been amazing
totally transformational for us and we
had a plan
every single month we had a plan we
would sit down on saturday mornings
together and we would decide where our
money would go
we cut up the one credit card we had
that we hardly even used
we refinanced our house we took side
jobs
we increased our income through
promotions we did everything that we
could to stay focused together
and before you knew it we had paid it
all off
that's powerful and i think you know the
secret
and we've talked about partnership a
little bit already but for me it was
you know the promise to each other to
always be in partnership
to have patience with the process and to
have positive cash flow dave
yeah that always helps yeah
so uh you guys almost make this sound
too easy what was the hardest part
um we were talking about this a little
bit
it wasn't i don't want to act like it
was easy but
once we got put our mind to it it wasn't
that hard
so the thing that was somewhat
challenging was from time to time
you know we would get distracted and
with things like well
you know maybe we should continue to
give to retirement or maybe
i want to go off on this business
venture and do well-intentioned things
with our money but
it really wasn't the time so we would
talk through those things and just
bring ourselves back to the process here
and just stay focused on
this this baby step two and so the
challenge was just the endurance to stay
focused for that long you know your your
story is really interesting
in in one respect because listening to
you you're very articulate
intelligent um you're not people who
just
uh you know uh kowtow and follow any old
thing
uh but one of the biggest problems
people have
honestly out there is that and me
included when it comes to something like
this is am i going
to submit myself to the proven
process and something somehow youtube
decided we're going to submit to this
we're going to do it
what do you attribute that to where the
partnership came that's where it came in
we looked at each other eye to eye every
week and went
we're still committed to this so anytime
there was a temptation
or there was something that came in our
way or you know
amazon tempted me to buy something else
i'd look at mike and we go no
we have dreams and plans and goals and
you know dave we want to give
and we want to be you know wealthy along
the way
we want to teach our children mike's
children how to do the same and
i think that was a big motivator for us
with our family
and knowing the kind of legacy that we
want to leave behind as well
yeah for sure so what you did was
and this isn't isn't vernacular that we
normally use but this is exactly what
they
what you did you practiced commitment
every week you
recommitted to commitment and every week
you got together and committed to
commitment and then over time it became
your way of being so when these new
ideas these new temptations came your
way
nope we're not we're not going to do
that right and my guess is you also
started practicing
co-parenting and you also started
practicing co-calendaring right and
co-eating and go exercising is that fair
to say
yeah that's pretty accurate guess yep
yeah i tell people all the time and i'm
not being hyperbolic but this
changed everything for us we were more
driven in our careers more driven
in fitness and health more driven in
parenting i mean
everything that we've done has been
better because we've been locked in
financially wow yeah i'm snowballing in
my business now that we're done doing
this personally
i'm so proud of you guys well done got a
copy of chris hogan's book for you
everyday millionaires uh that's
definitely the next step in your all's
journey the next chapter in your story
absolutely amazing
very well done mike and marianne
richmond virginia 172
thousand dollars paid off in 27 months
making 150 to 200 count it down let's
hear a debt free scream
three two one
[Applause]
wow it is amazing
if you submit yourself to a proven thing
you're going to get those results why do
we all
push against that i do they submitted
themselves to one another every week too
also yeah that and what a great practice
to start america i'll tell you what man
man powerful well done they're rock
stars absolute rock stars
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today first john 4 1
beloved do not believe every spirit
but test the spirits to see whether they
are from god
for many false prophets have gone out
into the world
bret sugar said words can inspire
thoughts can provoke but
only action truly brings you closer to
your dreams
yep otherwise you'd be called a dreamer
no i'm a dreamer you gotta go do it man
there it is just you gotta you know when
in doubt bust something
bust into it i mean you just gotta do it
all right let's move quickly to calls
before john sings again
lindsay is with us in phoenix arizona hi
lindsay how are you
good how are you better than i deserve
what's up
um well i'm a single mom and
i have 50 000 um
in savings wow so
should i use that for a down payment on
a house
um because my income isn't that high or
if i should invest it
um i guess i'm kind of just like suck on
what to do with it
what's your income um
this year it should be 52
000 a year but i've usually
like the last whatever six years it's
been like 26 or less
so why is it so high now um i moved
and i got a different job good for you
good for you how many kids you got and
what ages
i'm just one and she's six oh good
okay so a single mom making 52 thousand
dollars a year
and in phoenix arizona and you have 50
000
in cash where'd you get 50 000 in cash
um
i just i saved um a lot like i saved all
my texts
um returned ever since i had my daughter
and just i lived at home
for about almost five years
um until recently when i moved um
so that helped and then how old are you
just working really hard i'm 29.
okay yeah you're you're and that's
impressive
making 25 000 bucks and you save 50.
man that's a grind out yeah i thought
i've always been
like much of a favor um but
uh my daughter's father he basically
stole a lot of money from me and ruined
my credit score so
after all of that i just really put my
mind to it
and saved and got my credit score up
girl you're a warrior that's what i'm
talking about good for you
i'm proud of you well done very well
done
well um what we teach our baby steps
and baby step one is a thousand dollars
two is to be debt free
other than your home you've done those
two three is to have an emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses
are you debt-free yeah
i mean just my car payment oh well that
would be a deal
okay how much do you how much do we owe
on said car
um i think maybe a little less than ten
thousand
i should be done in like a year now
okay so if you were going to follow our
plan and do what we teach
which is obviously what i recommend and
it's how i live and it's how i teach
people to live
you would pay off your car today
and you would take some of the remaining
the remaining forty thousand dollars
and we would set some of it aside as an
emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses
i'm gonna call that twenty thousand
dollars
okay and so thirty of your fifty has
been allocated to paying off the car and
20 of it's set aside so that's that
leaves us twenty thousand dollars of
still asking the question what do we do
with it
you follow what i did
10 on the car i'm sorry 10 on the car 20
in the rainy day fund
leaving us 20 to do something else with
right okay and right now it's just
another regular bank account just
okay it doesn't have to be invested to
be fancy
you are way ahead of people who make 10
times more than you make
they can't save a nickel you're amazing
so now what i would do if i were in your
shoes i would leave that 20 000 in a
separate bank account
i'm going to name that bank account
house fund
and now that we don't have a car payment
and we're going to live on a budget
and we're going to make twice as much as
you ever made
i'm going to put money on top of that 20
and money on top of that 20 and money on
top of that 20
and in two or three years i'm going to
buy a house with a really large down
payment and i'm going to use that
down payment money for that account
okay meanwhile you never borrow money
again
when you do buy the house you put it on
a 15-year fixed
where the payment is no more than a
fourth of your take-home pay
but i'm going to guess and say you're
probably going to put down 100 000
on a house
i don't know that's a lot that gives me
like
the thing is you wanna know how i did
that let me help you i did that okay
you saved 50. you saved 50 000 making
25. now you make 52.
i think you're gonna save 100 really
fast
i know but i still think you're going to
save really i think really really fail
you make
twice what you used to make it's just in
your nature
you're a warrior and you're a saver and
you just
you're incredible and i want you to do a
budget with your six-year-old daughter i
want you to bring her into this
and let her practice it and this this
is how you're going to start to change
this family we're going to buy us
we're gonna buy us a house baby girl
that's exactly right and every week
she's gonna get to make the little
chain with you or whatever game you'll
come up with but she's gonna learn
how awesome her mom is what an absolute
um great mother and saver and
planner and builder her mom is and she's
going to learn what a strong
invested woman looks like and you're
going to she's going to walk alongside
you it's going to be
a great journey for both of you it is
interesting to me in a culture that has
completely gone wussified where
everybody spends all their time being a
victim
everybody spends all their time looking
for something to be offended by
i get this sweet little voice on the
phone who is a stronger warrior
than almost anybody out there listening
man
that woman's incredible yes she is and
you you
and and so unassuming you would never
think
that conan the barbarian lives in her
soul with a giant sword
yeah yeah yeah it's just so sweet
man oh
but she looks at that baby girl every
morning and says we're gonna do this
yeah right she's got a big big y
fifty-two percent single mom
lived below the poverty level not her
yeah
she doubled her income she made a move
yeah she lived at home for a while
moved out save fifty thousand dollars
listen if you're out there and you had a
tendency to whine
after that call you're done now just
shut up euro it's over now
your whining is over now back back in
college we called her the curve buster
right yeah yeah we all got c's
everyone's going to get moved
except for you got a 97 that's her right
except for the one who messed the curve
up yeah yeah yeah we're gonna grade on a
curve
oh well then there's
then there's lindsey from phoenix good
for you
way to go kiddo so proud of you well
done
you know what's interesting is um
the number of times people face uh
adversity which is all of us sometimes
and most of us last year yeah
and then the choice and it's a choice
yeah on how to react to it
you choose i'm gonna wail and scream and
wait on the democrats to send me money
yeah
or i'm gonna wail and scream about
whatever
internet story i found i'm gonna find
somebody that will
because of that guy whoever voted for
that guy tell me what i want whichever
guy
whoever voted for them you're stark
craven evil both of you
both of you that's right and so you must
be punished you must be canceled you
must be killed
or you know what i'm going to do i'm
going to show you i'm going to live
in rage and anger so that i poison
myself
hoping you die right i'm gonna i'm gonna
ruin all of my relationships and drive
like an
idiot and slam doors in my house and
yell at my kids that'll show whoever's
on the other end of that computer
keyboard
it's just nonsense right or or you can
be lindsey
you can just start nickel and dime in
your way and say i'm in charge of my
life
i'm going to practice and i've got i've
got it nobody's going
the lone ranger is not coming i'm going
to practice patience i'm gonna do it
i love it get on the back of the turtle
great show guys great show
that puts this hour of the day ramsey
show in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
you